welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Elf Don
favro 2003 holiday classic that I
believe led directly to Iron Man in the
Mandalorian and a movie filled with
great jokes attention to detail that
makes me appreciate this more and more
every year that I rewatch it so let's
take this scene by scene for dozens of
details that you might have overlooked
the film opens with a story book intro
narrated by Papa elf Bob newart sitcom
Legend from the Bob newart show in
newart this book we'll see by the film's
end is the children's book that buddy
writes to recount the events the film
elf a short story of a tall tale
according to director John favro in the
DVD commentary track his intention was
to create the feel of a classic family
movie and he felt that a story book
Motif helped cement and a reverent
comedy like elf to feel a touch more
familiar using the story book Motif that
we saw in movies like Snow White
Sleeping Beauty and Timeless classic
Shrek when pitching to direct David
Baron bomb's script Fabro laid out three
principles one he wanted the movie to
look like a rank and bass Christmas
special come to life two he wanted to
make a true family Christmas movie with
none of the vulgarity that Fabro was
known for for movies like swingers and
three he wanted the movie to be a
Timeless classic able to be played every
year without feeling dated so notice how
this movie's less reliant on like a ton
of Technology a ton of topical
references they're much more subtle in
this movie it's kind of the same
approach that Chris Columbus used for
home alone in my opinion it's why elf
and Home Alone hold up as annual comedy
must watches and other Christmas movie
attempts don't work quite as well while
Papa elf narrates most of what we see on
the page you can read some words he
doesn't say elves can't tell a lie which
is part of what makes buddy such a fish
out of water in New York he's
psychologically unable to lie and
doesn't like others who sit on Thrones
of lies behind Papa elf in this room is
a baby rocker which I'm going to assume
is for his grandkid though this must be
way far behind him because it would be a
lot bigger the interior of Papa elf's
room is the same Shade of Pale white
that we'll see throughout the North Pole
according to John favro the pale white
backgrounds function as both a visual
homage to many iconic Christmas tv
specials from ranked bass and contrast
the bright colors of all the elves
costumes Papa elf and Buddy are dressed
in these similar greens and yellows as
the boss elf in Rudolph the Reno's
reindeer why weren't you at elf practice
Papa elf explains that there are only
three jobs available to elves one making
shoes while the cobbler sleeps
referencing the brother's Grim tail The
Elves and the shoem maker I like how
these elves gripe couldn't even make a
clock but this shot is also the first of
many instances of force perspective
imagery in this movie this is a
technique used to create the illusion of
size differences by putting some objects
closer to the camera and others further
away Peter Jackson mastered this with
the hobbits in The Lord of the Rings
films that were really the biggest films
at this time in the early OTS and here
the sleeping cobbler is actually far
closer to the camera while the table is
way deeper than it seems with the
segment on the right actually further
back of that sitting elf but they still
had his legs hanging over it to make it
seem like it was all on the same plane
really everyone is looking far behind
the cobbler instead of directly at him
favro does this throughout the movie and
it's so smooth and seemingly effortless
that we don't notice it but actually a
ton of effort just went into this little
gag now the second career option for
elves is baking cookies and trees
obviously reference to the keer elves I
like how when the tree catches on fire
one of these elves shouts I want to make
shoes the third and best elf career is
working in Santa's Workshop we see the
elves packing pink Barbie dolls ET of
sketches Monopoly board games Mr Potato
Heads even Bob the Builder plushies all
of these toys are owned by different
companies including giants like Hasbro
Mattel and Milton Bradley and we meet
the lead elf Ming Ming only two weeks
left till Christmas an uncredited Cameo
by Peter Billingsley who played Ralphie
Parker in A Christmas Story and I'm
going to assume that he we red ear is an
odd to the Red Rider BB gun favro and
billing Lee have long been collaborators
billing Lee was cast in Iron Man as the
Stark engineer that obadi stain yells at
Tony Stark was able to build this in a
cave with a box of scraps later named
William gter Reva who returns to
Spider-Man far from home as part of Team
Mysterio the story book pages flip
through the opening credits and I love
to pause on the flips because you can
see this Jolly looking polar bear
hanging a star ornament these Pages all
foreshadow what we see in the movie
including the creepy Jack of the box and
the snowball fight we meet baby buddy in
a Catholic orphanage this orphanage
along with several scenes in this movie
was actually filmed at a former mental
institution Riverview Hospital in
British Columbia this is where they shot
the offices of Greenway press the
greenway press mail room the police
precinct and even the spacious Hobs
apartment in Manhattan Santa is played
by the late great Ed Asner another
sitcom Legend who's in the mared Tyler
Moore Show he would later voice Carl
Frederickson and pixars up the elves
celebrate Christmas with shots of milk
because only the Gnomes drank liquor and
while they all dance notice that Papa
elf sits alone huddled over a desk in
the background Santa Towers over the
elves another example of forc
perspective Ed Asner was standing far
close to the camera while the elves are
all further away their eyelines pointed
several feet behind Asner this effect is
even more impressive with baby buddy in
the foreground making him seem like a
really big baby to the elves who find
him in Santa's bag they get the name
Buddy from the little buddy diapers we
never learned Buddy's real life name
anywhere in this movie and some of the
most fun examples of force perspective
shots is right here with toddler buddy
on Papa elf's lap Papa elf's legs and
hands actually belong to a child actor
who is strategically obscured and framed
in front of Bob newart who leans in his
top half from behind them several feet
behind I love it it's the same kind of
practical trickery that favro would use
in the shot of Pepper Pot sticking her
hand in Tony Stark's chest and Iron Man
Robert Danny Jr actually squatted
beneath the prosthetic chest with a hole
in it but the more ambitious example of
this is newart behind kid buddy on the
bike with the background moving behind
them so newart would have had to be on a
rolling platform far behind the kid in
the foreground with smaller hands on his
shoulders someone hidden right behind
him in school buddy learns the code of
elves one treat every day like it's
Christmas two there's room for everyone
on the nice list three the best way to
spread Christmas cheer is singing loud
for all to hear these rules actually
tell the story of this film to its end
the first rule simply characterizes
buddy as someone who just loves
Christmas so much the second rule plants
the seed for Buddy's father Walter Hobbs
to change his ways even though he starts
on Santa's naughty list the third rule
completes the character Arc of Joy
Buddy's love interest played by Zoe Des
Chanel who learns that she has to sing
loud for all to hear while will frell at
63 would Tower over these kids already
they still use Force perspective to make
him even bigger because these are Elf
kids they would be that much smaller so
will frell is super close to the camera
that girl next to him is f fur away from
the camera but they still look to smile
at each other really these actors are
looking past each other at pieces of
tape on the wall we see this technique
again in the next scene in the garage
multiple versions of Santa slay were
actually designed all in different sizes
a normal size one for Will frell and Ed
Asner later in the movie and a much
larger one for Bob newart this close-up
of newart passes Ferell on an Apple box
and Fabro cuts to frell as a smaller
actor wearing Papa El's hat passes
beneath him the movie acknowledges our
real world disbelief of Santa Claus elf
of course is all about Santa and him
being real while parents placing
presents under the the tree is just a
rumor but it also gets into the heart of
this movie's plot device restoring
Christmas spirit turning it into kind of
an energy crisis as Papa El puts it
simply a 21st century spin on the
centuries old notion that modern society
is lacking in what makes Christmas so
special Papa elf's cringle 3000 engine
has a 500 reindeer power jet turban
engine reindeer power not horsepower
love it buddy falls behind schedule
producing only 85 etch sketches in a day
but Ming Ming refuses to let him call
himself a cottonheaded nin muggins even
though later buddy loves to stuff his
face with cotton balls so he is kind of
cotton headed that way he sends him to
toy testing which is still one of the
funniest scenes of the movie to me from
his director's chair John faer actually
held a remote control that made the Jack
in the Box pop out on his command so
well phoh would always react
spontaneously his reactions are all
based on fa's playful timing but he over
hears Mingming and F fom reveal that
he's actually a human his room spins we
see him showering in a tiny shower still
wearing his hat because elves never take
off their hats he sleeps on two beds
pushed together he sings in the elf
choir and indeed bringing them down on a
whole octave like they said
earlier we see him savagely dunking on
them on the basketball court and there's
actually a deleted scene that showed
buddy tearing it up on the ice hockey
[Applause]
ring this is actually the one time we
see buddy in elf clothes that aren't
yellow and green because his team wears
purple the evil Jack of the Box laughs
over all of this which is always so
funny to me like out of everything that
is the taunt that disturbs him the most
in the bathroom buddy hides in I love
the tiny plunger and the little reindeer
toilet paper roll holder Papa elf hands
him a photograph of his father Walter
Hobs played by actor James con and his
mother Susan Wells played by Jane
Bradbery they use an old photograph of
Khan when his appearance looked closer
to his look in The Godfather as Sunny
Corleone buddy runs past Arctic Puffin
polar bear cub and baby walrus two of
them voiced by John favro while Leon the
Snowman was voiced by musician Leon
Redbone the third one of those little
guys was voiced by Henry Harry house
elf's adorable stop motion was handled
by The choto Brothers Studio that
specializes in handcrafted creatures
puppets and stop motion they did killer
clowns from outer space Team America
World Police and Bob the Builder Leon
says that he was once a young cumulous
nimbus cloud even though Santa says Leon
hasn't been anywhere because he doesn't
have any feet he doesn't account for
Leon having transformed via
precipitation cycle and for water I
guess having memory even before magical
snowman enchantment Santa instructs
buddy that in New York there are like 30
raised pizzas and that they all claim to
be the original but the real one is on
11 this is a big deal to John favro who
loves raise pizza and actually worked it
into Iron Man just because I brought
pizza back from New York doesn't mean it
went bad uh-huh sure doesn't oh boy all
right well this stays with me then come
on here you can have a peie thank you
Santa reveals that Walter is on the
naughty list and we get this frantic
zoom into the list which Sean fa said he
based on Sam Ry shot in Evil Dead 2o
we're introduced to Walter as he takes
books back from a nun at an orphanage
there's originally more to the scene
where Walter ended up giving the nun a
3-week extension but I always wondered
if this was the same Catholic orphanage
that buddy started in Papa elf gives
buddy the snow globe it's really large
in new heart's hand will farell holds a
smaller prop and when they hug will
farell is actually hugging a child actor
Mr Narwhal scares away Arctic puff and
polar bear cub and baby
walrus bye buddy hope you find your dad
thanks Mr Narwhal and that again is John
fao's voice I love the detail that buddy
starts off on a large Iceberg but when
he floats up to the candy cane Forest
the iceburg has melted down to a tiny
chunk it's actually a stunt man wearing
Buddy's costume to walk on Top This
Glacier and then he runs into this
hissing raccoon that attacks buddy and
this hiss was also from John Fabro I
like how buddy assumes that he's
friendly just like Arctic Puffin and the
other animals that he knew but nope not
at all and I love this shot does someone
need a
hug I just wanted to hug it sounds like
they used a monkey scream for the
raccoon sound but he makes it to New
York coming in through the Lincoln
Tunnel location scouting for Elf
happened only a few months after
September 11th which favro recalled was
a difficult period as the city was a lot
more guarded about giving out shooting
permits than ever like Sam Ry Spider-Man
elf lives on as an early o New York
movie that's really all about bringing
New Yorkers together this Montage of
Buddy interacting with New Yorkers was
actually filmed gorilla style frell and
a crew of just one camera guy let
themselves loose throughout the city and
will farell will just have random
interactions with New Yorkers like this
man with the beard and the red hoodie
and joggers was just a regular New
Yorker that will frell spontaneously ran
up to and that's why in the background
of a lot of these shots you could see
other New Yorkers smiling at this idiot
that they know from SNL running around
now this movie actually did shoot in the
lobby of the Empire State Building which
again was a really difficult permit for
the filmmakers to obtain in the
immediate aftermath of 911 it was really
now the most recognizable skyscraper
landmark of the city but the elevator
scene was actually filmed on a set like
the real elevators in the Empire State
Building don't have all of these buttons
Amy sederis plays Walter's assistant Deb
sederis would go on to play pel Moto and
John favos the Mandalorian and knowing
sedaris's manic improv style I'm pretty
sure her F call about decl eight kittens
was improvised well I don't know Connie
I've never declawed kittens before how
many eight to give is better than to
receive and if you're giving a gift to a
kid it needs to be fun for them and even
better more fun for you to use with them
right to play is better than to merely
give and kiwi Co makes awesome crates it
lets you give the kids in your life the
gifts they'll love to play and build
either alone or together each month kiwo
delivers a crate to your door with fun
Hands-On projects that are designed by
experts and tested by kids promoting
creativity and Innovation through Steam
science technology engineering art and
math activities there are nine different
lines to choose from so there's
something for every interest in age this
month we got a build your own pinball
machine which is super satisfying to put
together and is now the new oh right
we're supposed to be at work thing at
the office if you're not ready to
subscribe or you just need a single
crate kiwo also offers a variety of
individual crates at the Kiwi Co store
if you're really feeling the holiday
spirit there's all kinds of specific
holiday projects too like this cozy
glowing fireplace or Santa slle
automaton each crate comes with a
kid-friendly magazine that empowers the
kids to learn more about the projects
and complete them on their own every ke
crate is a complete project so you're
not going to be running out to the craft
store hunting down a special glue or
anything like that to get started with
kiwo today head to ki.com rockstars and
use code rockstars for 50% off your
first month of a kiico subscription in
Walter's office we see a book titled the
Sea King next to another book titled the
girl who lost her smile both of these
are real books the Sea King was
published in 2002 by author Jane yolen
the girl who lost her smile by km alal
tells of a young girl in Bagdad who goes
in search of her missing smile on the
walls we see Lucy and the Pirates by
Glen Petri and Mr balinsky Bagels by
Ellen Schwarz but he sings what he wants
from Walter and they all gradually
realize that this guy ain't a Christmas
Graham but he mentions Susan Wells and
it freaks Walter out think we should
call security good idea I like to
whisper too now the shot Cuts away but
you can actually start to see James Khan
begin to break into a smile because who
would break character at this great bit
now one of the empire state buildings
guards holding buddy is Will far's own
brother Patrick frell he's on the right
he's theone who tells him to go back to
gimbals and due to the filmmaker's
inability to use the name Macy because
they were refused by Macy's corporate
the department store gimbals takes its
place in the story believe it or not
gimbals was actually a real store that
operated for a hundred years between
1842 until it shuttered in 1987 it was a
rival to Macy's and also had a major New
York City location in Herold Square
which opened in Midtown in 1910 but here
they use CGI to recreate gimbal's
storefront we don't spend too long
looking at it
because sorry the way he just Teeters
over like a tree in an interview with
rolling stone faver said that Macy's was
willing to let elf film in its store but
they were unwilling to budge on the
movie revealing that its store Santa
isn't the real Santa so they had to
build a set version of it internally
that's how committed Macy's is to it
fison love plays the manager of gimbals
Wanda Sykes was originally set to play
the role but she dropped out last minute
and Faison filled in but notice how his
name tag on his vest still reads Wanda
so the character's name is still like
technically Wanda we meet Zoe Des Chanel
as Joy looking really weird in her
natural blonde hair color based on
everything she played after this
according to John Fabro Joy was
originally not a singing part until Zoe
disel audition and got the part when the
filmmakers learned that she could sing
they expanded Joy's part to include
singing in a small Arc where she's too
nervous to share her Talent with the
world now remember part of what made the
I like to whisper too bit so great is
how fast buddy just appears at Walter's
side and there's a similar gag here with
joy in the shower where we last leave
buddy sneaking down the hall toward the
bathroom and then joy in the shower and
then bam Buddy's just already seated
there on the sink because elves are
sneaky while many pointed out that the
lyrics of Baby It's Cold Outside are
kind of creepy this song is not actually
about a guy pressuring a woman it's
about two people in a couple flirting
with each other the woman is flirting
just as hard back with a guy and halfway
through the song she turns the tables on
him and does it back stop trying to ruin
Christmas spirit internet this is cute
leave this song Alone Now this scene of
James Conan finding buddies sleeping in
the window was actually one of the first
scene screen for the new line Executives
and if you think about it removed from
its context this scene just doesn't play
well like comes off it's kind of creepy
and strange now Joy reveals to buddy
that she has to shower at work because
they shut her utilities off earlier
drafts of Elf told a slightly darker
story where its character struggle to
learn the meaning of Christmas I like
this detail though because it shows how
Joy wouldn't mind a date where they just
run around New York looking at bigger
and bigger Christmas trees comedian Arty
Lane plays gimbal Santa and I love how
this little kid named Paul once buddy
calls this Santa a fake this little kid
just keeps saying fake fake fake I'm a
fake yes how'd you like to be dead huh
huge fight breaks out buddy gets
arrested Walter barrs him out and takes
them to a pediatrition played by
director John Fabro but he meets Carolyn
who appears later in the movie when
Michael reads off Santa's list on the
news and she wants to Susie talks a lot
buddy moves in with the Hobs family with
his wife Emily Mary steenbergen and
their son Michael Daniel Tay buddy decks
out their home as well I love the fork
and spoon display hanging over the
dining table during dinner now buddy Dow
in an entire bottle of soda was achieved
with a pipe placed in the bottle that is
carefully obscured by Will Ferrell's
face but he thinks that all that normal
humans eat is spaghetti so he makes
again for breakfast and lunch and I love
how he wrote Emily's name in beautiful
cursive boss Mr Greenway scolds him for
signing off on blank pages in the print
that Walter earlier said they didn't
need to reprint buddy nearly gets hit by
another taxi and walks Michael home from
school allowing buddy to show how good
he is at snowball packing I love this
scene favro paid homage to John Woo with
the slow motion dive in the throw I love
how for that last throw buddy uses the
snowball packed by Michael because
Michael really only had time to pack one
snowball while buddy made dozens so this
way he makes Michael feel included the
moment buddy jumps onto the tree was
actually accomplished through what's
called a Texas switch it's an old school
filmmaking technique where will frell
exits the frame and a double takes over
to perform per formed stunt there's a
trampoline hidden in the cushions of the
sofa allowing ferals double to get some
vertical height in the movie special
effects Department had a crew member
hidden to knock off the tree while the
onset electrician flicked off the lights
just at the right time the whole thing
is just accomplished in one take and
it's awesome buddy Shadows Walter at
work in the office he sits on this tiny
pig in the corner because he's more
accustomed to smaller Furniture but this
pig is also submerged from this book
that he's reading Pig Malon which fav
said was intentional to reflect what's
happening to Buddy as an outsider being
changed by their environment I like how
he has a colorful mug while Walter just
drinks out of a plain mug the phone
rings buddy the what's your favorite
color put that down oh my God so if you
think about it the elves in the North
Pole all wear clothes dominated by
vibrant colors so their favorite colors
are really a huge part of how they get
to know each other Andy RoR and
tenacious D's Kyle Gas play writers
Morris and Eugene who pitching to bring
miles Finch the famous children's author
played in this movie by Peter Dinklage
buddy gets drunk with a mail room worker
played by Mark akison a Canadian actor
who auditioned for the role of a truck
driver in a scene cut from the movie
probably earlier when buddy was walking
along the side of the road in the
Canadian woods he tells buddy that he's
26 and Fabro knows that this actor does
not look 26 but they kept the line in
buddy starts a tickle fight with this
guy after Walter refused to play along
in a tickle fight earlier buddy takes
Joy on their date first to the diner
with the world's greatest cup of coffee
this is the New York that he fell in
love with on his first day here a cab
almost runs them over the yellow ones
don't stop but this taxy was actually
CGI they go ice skating and 30 Rock and
they share a smooch now when miles Finch
arrives in the publishing office office
screenwriter David Baron bomb actually
cameos as that Greenway press employee
reading the newspaper we see Peter dlish
in this role years before he was cast
his Tyrion Lannister and Game of Thrones
favro wanted to cast Peter Dinklage
because favro had seen him in living in
Oblivion and was a huge fan I like how
in this movie we never hear what miles's
big pitch was Buddy naive greatly
insults miles and while will farell
plays the scene with complete sincerity
on this one line he adds just a little
bit of salt on the take to make it sting
does Santa know that you left the
workshop so Miles beats the crap crap
out of Buddy and Walter explodes in Rage
at buddy buddy leaves a goodbye note on
an ET a sketch with the snow globe
because the snow globe would have been
his only way of finding his dad it's
kind of like leaving your keys after a
breakup Walter decides to walk out of
his pitch meeting in order to find buddy
buddy walks out on a bridge which is a
not to George Bailey's dark moment and
It's a Wonderful Life Santa crash lands
in Central Park and the third act shifts
into kind of a Rudolph the rednose
reindeer storyline as Santa has to ask
the outsider won't you fly my sleigh
tonight I like how when buddy first
approaches Santa Santa's like back off
slick showing his street smarts from the
thousands of times he's visited New York
City New York 1 reports on the scene
where buddy is spotted trudging through
the brush and will farell walks exactly
with the big steps and the arm swings to
recreate the famous 1967 Patterson
gimlin footage allegedly showing Bigfoot
and Bluff Creek California it's such a
deep cut and it's so funny Charlotte
denen interviews a random New Yorker who
proceeds to hit on her telling her that
her eyes tell the story you've got a
great mouth this is Matt Walsh UCB
co-founder and star of HBO's vep in a
2023 interview with AV club the actress
Laurer said that Matt Walsh improvised
all these lines and which is why she's
laughing during the segment later
Charlotte interviews an NYPD officer
laua said that that was a real NYPD
officer who improvised his lines as well
and we meet the Central Park Rangers
these don't actually exist these were
imagined by John favro as an homage to
the ring rates from The Fellowship of
the Ring his idea for them was quote a
dark mysterious Force the reporter
Charlotte mentions controversial crowd
control tactics at a Simon and car Funko
concert in summer of 85 that are still
under investigation which is hilarious
because nothing would be more chill than
an outdoor summer concert with Simon
Garfunkle and this is in 1985 which
would be like 15 years after they broke
up so like a reunion concert with Sim
Garfunkle originally 's climax was going
to involve NYPD chases and stunts on the
Empire State Building but John favos
scaled it down to just a crisis of
Christmas spirit so that it felt more
like a Frank CA its Wonderful Life type
Climax and we get a quick glimpse of
Santa's list which includes Victoria
down English riding saddle with Leathers
in a crop Drew Davidson Rockham sockum
robots Andreas nean complete set of
titanium drivers new golf club Nathan
tienor Apple iBook laptop computer with
one gig hard drive and a built-in CD
burner Michael Hobs real hboard with
high 145 Thunder tracks 52 mm Spitfire
classic wheels and bolts Jimmy Miller
Hot Wheels turbo Ultra racetrack with
six cars power launcher and a track
cleaner and Penny Gibbs and Old McDonald
farm something Santa tells Michael that
they can't just get the news crew to
come and talk to him because Christmas
spirit is about believing not seeing so
Michael reads from the list on the news
to connect with the people who are
watching where their hearts desires are
he includes Charlotte denen who wants a
Tiffany engagement ring and her
boyfriend to stop dragging his feet and
commit
already and I'd love how this gives a
huge boost on the clausometer which
could just be from this being so
specific that everybody watching at home
is like her face says this is real but I
also like to think it might have come
from Charlotte's boyfriend out there
wherever he was maybe watching this at
home suddenly realizing yeah maybe now's
a good time to go buy a ring and pop the
question Joy helps by singing in front
of the crowd Santa Claus is coming to
town and Emily is the first to join her
no
you've been bad or good whenever I see
the scene I just kind of think about how
in 2007 Mary steenbergen woke up from
minor arm surgery and said that she
constantly hears music in her head like
her reality has turned into a musical
I'm not joking this is something she has
said in interviews and after a few
months she had to just kind of get used
to it and now it has led to a
songwriting career meanwhile buddies
sworn enemy the Jack of the Box gives
him one last
scare Santa says I'm getting too old for
this job like and Lethal Weapon I'm too
old for this
they lose the engine and nearly crash
over this unhoused man with the radio
around his neck this guy's name is Craig
Castell and he's known as radio man he's
cameo in over 300 films and TV shows
that are shot in the New York area
including elf 30 Rock The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 he's become a friend to
several different film Crews he helps
them put up no parking signs to kind of
help the Pas clear the set and he just
kind of always knows where Steph is
shooting in New York so they put him in
everything and I just love to see this
guy show up the last boost they need is
to Walter to finally just join in the
Caroline cuz he's just mouting the words
and he finally sings the song which
launches the sleigh and it's off into
the sky I like how as buddy waves
goodbye to Michael the four Central Park
Rangers are just standing behind the
crowd glaring at them we get a fade
transition from the Empire State
Building to Buddy snow globe which stays
at home in the Hobs home Walter plays
for Joy singing old l z buddy unwraps a
big jug of maple syrup and it looks like
Emily ended up with a sexy lingerie for
that special someone in Walter's new
publishing office his first dollar came
with him framed on the wall along with
frame photos of Michael from his old
office and a poster for his new book elf
it's a Smash Hit and it's a story we've
been hearing all along the final shot of
the movie brings buddy and Joie to the
North Pole with their daughter named
Susie after Buddy's mother Susan Wells
and they let Arctic Puffin sit inside
with them and we end with one final
great shot of force perspective but this
I think is my favorite one because we
start with Will farell Crossing new
heart's seated body we actually see new
heart's full body for a few frames and
it appears to all be connected it's
actually just one long costume d rped
over itself in a specific way with new
Heart Way further behind and a second
set of legs in the foreground where will
frell sits down Papa elf's body only
looks slightly weird if you just pause
it on these specific frames and it's
just amazing how well this practical
effect works and how much attention to
detail the entire film crew put into
this holiday classic hey happy holidays
from new rock stars thanks for
supporting us this year and try not to
crush the legs of your loved ones by
sitting on their laps unexpectedly I'll
see you next time bye
everybody
[Music]